as the House Judiciary Committee widens
its in Teachman investigation where does
the public stand and how do today's
polls compared to past polls about
impeaching Nixon and Clinton in the July
poll 45% said Trump should be impeached
and removed from office the opinions of
Democrats and Republicans differ
dramatically independents were split 46
yes 51 no the year before Richard Nixon
left office 24% said that he should be
impeached using a different question a
year later 58% said the charges were
serious enough to warrant his being
removed in 11 polls no more than 35
percent said that Clinton should be
impeached in each case public opinion on
impeachment impacted congressional
elections Nixon resigned and the
Republicans lost seats for Clinton
impeachment efforts backfired
he remained in office and Democrats
gained seats House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
has tried to slow walk impeachment talk
because she knows it is a political
loser now without broader public support
do you think Democrats will gain from an
impeachment inquiry let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI